Pete Davidson and Chase sui wonders soak
up the sun the two have done plenty to
fuel romance rumors and et's Source tell
us the pair like each other a lot and
have been spending a lot of time
together and their latest outing a
Hawaii vacation the two were snapped
taking an ocean dip Chase in a green
bikini with Pete donning some colorful
swim trunks yum
and the swimwear throws back to where
they first met filming in a pool for
bodies bodies bodies
we're back at the beach eagle-eyed fans
took note of the SNL alum's tattoos or
lack thereof I don't know like I I just
think he was like I want something
that's there that I can't you know get
rid of it's so cute guys it is cute last
year the comedian famously added some
tribute ink while dating Kim Kardashian
he posted this uh the selfie sort of uh
right and and there's they're reading
into it saying that there's a tattoo
that says Kim
um yeah he has a few tattoos few cute
ones you know that he got I think my
favorite one it says here it says my
girl is a lawyer and that one's really
cute but like that's what tattoo people
do right like they get tattoos of what's
going on in their life it's really lit
and fun and crazy and fast forward to
the new year and a new love those cats
were seemingly removed and yes as was
the infamous branding Kim one isn't a
tattoo it's actually a branding
like a
branding I don't know like I I just
think he was like I want something
that's there that I can't you know get
rid of my tattoos because he's in the
process of getting rid of his arm tats
and his neck tat so he's like I don't
want to be able to get rid of it or to
cover it up and I just wanted it like
there as like a scar on me what's your
favorite thing about it
um
he's just super genuine and the ocean
getaway follows the couple's trip to
Universal Studios last week where they
were spotted sharing a smooch and
packing on the PDA while taking in the
Thrills I've been fortunate enough to
have some great relationships and you
know uh honesty is always really
important E.T Source notes that Pete and
Chase are both funny and says their
connection is not troll Pete likes that
chase is down to earth and cool
[Music]